Please welcome my friend Chelsea Clinton.
(audience applause)
Hi everybody.
Hi.
Oh, your hair is so long!
I know, my hair is ridiculously long.
Hi friend.
Ooh, you worked out.
Oh gosh.
My children are large, Drew.
And you have two boys.
I do.
And my two and a half year old's a giant.
Okay.
So the last time you came here was like,
the morning after the insurrection.
It was the morning after the insurrection.
And here we are, in the middle of a new war.
And how do we persevere?
How do we go about are days
when such difficult things are happening?
Oh gosh, Drew.
Well, there is a lot happening.
I mean, here in our city of New York,
across our country and certainly around the world.
We see the ongoing humanitarian crisis in Ukraine.
Although we know that Ukraine isn't
the only country in the world that is under
kind of war and violence and kind of threat
from outside or inside.
And I think either we can drown in the despair
or we can decide to try to do something about it.
And I think there is a lot that we can do.
I mean, for those of us, with resources,
we can donate to the international rescue committee,
and so many of the amazing organizations
who are on the front lines trying to give people food
and medical support and hope.
We can put continued pressure,
kind of especially for those of us who live in democracies,
to have a unified effort to stand up to Putin
and all of his brutality,
because I think ultimately, Drew, optimism is a moral choice
and I think it is the more moral choice
to choose to be optimistic, to choose to believe
that our efforts and our energies can make a difference,
because otherwise we just all like put our covers
over our heads and I don't think that's gonna
make us feel very good.
Right, I think that's then just seeding to hopelessness.
I would much rather try to act hopeful
and try to create more hope in the world.
So, that happiness you talk about is hard,
one, because we know we have all tried to do our part.
And you just did it.
You just did it.
(audience applause)
I always love that you and I also,
and I cannot hold a candle to your experience
growing up in front of everybody.
I just, I love asking you life advice
because as you are very full of grace
and I don't know, how do you do it?
How do you remain this full of grace
while the world is difficult,
while people are divided or different?
What's your one foot in front of the other?
Well, I think being myself, somewhat stubbornly.
I'm terrible at being other people.
But I just am not an actress.
I don't have those jeans like you do.
And I can't do it in real life.
I can't fake anything.
And yet then I do know I have to take care of myself
so that I can hopefully take care of others,
the others in kind of the smaller world of my family
and the others in the bigger sense of the work
that I feel called to do,
whether as a as an author or an advocate.
So I spend a lot of time with my kids
because they just bring me so much joy.
And I spend a lot of time running
because I find running is like my meditative space.
And I'm also, I'm quite religious.
And I was able to finally go back in person to church
a few weeks ago, which meant a huge amount to me
to be able to be kind of in the sanctuary,
was a very different experience than livestream.
Although like God bless my minister
for just never giving up on those of us
on the other side of the screen,
who she couldn't see or kind of be with
in kind of physical community.
And so all of that really matters to me
and is then how I try to help remind myself
that I do matter.
So then I can try to do more work that I hope
creates more more possibility for more people
and more places.
And you do.
(audience applause)
Church, running, stubbornly being yourself.
All three of those things seem doable,
attainable, admirable.
When you move your body, you do shift your chemistry.
(upbeat music)